come gather young people come and join
your hands
we take in Wall Street and we make in
demands and we're heeding the call and
we're crying for help only 1% of us have
well
but first we need folders we need to
make signs but to do so it seems that we
need some supplies we need poster board
I can't make it myself
but it's ten cents a sheet at the store
it's on sale an example of economies of
scale it's so evil they're saying that
freedom's
done little to stop operations from
keeping the wealth at the top but at
what point in history could a kid and a
king both have clean water to drink
[Music]
George Washington was the richest man of
his age but he lost all his teeth at a
very young age because they didn't have
scope and they all crapped in trays were
not wealthy
now this fountains on streets from which
clean water pours $4 generics had all
big box stores a sultan and the student
both have iPhone fours it's not fair
come get the young people come on
everyone
and I'll tell you a tale of a fortunate
side
he's born in a country and given vaccine
and rendered immune to all kinds of
disease the Kardashians are on all his
TVs it's not perfect see banks don't
need bailouts on that we agree
so let's start up and grouping let's
take to the streets
so will you know that
we're racist
[Music]
you